[Music]
foreign
cancellation we turn to recovery coach
and weight neutral trainer ashantis
Jones now these two meaningless job
titles fall under the umbrella of an
even more meaningless job title on our
website Jones refers to herself as a
wellness Advocate and offers paid
Wellness consultations she promises that
she never judges just supports this is
what a person uh you know most often
means these days when they say that
they're a wellness Advocate or life
coach or counselor even therapist what
they mean is that they will they will
cheer you on and offer vague support for
whatever Life Choices you've already
made what they what they most certainly
won't do and wouldn't know how to do
anyway is guide you towards better life
choices and a better life that would
require judgment you know you can't help
someone better themselves without
exercising judgment but judgment is bad
we're told which means that these
counselors and coaches will not actually
do any counseling or coaching Wellness
in this context doesn't mean physical
health and it certainly doesn't mean
mental or emotional health it means
something more like mental comfort
so they exist to make you feel
comfortable with your own dysfunction
they will not show the dysfunction or
help you navigate past it rather they
will convince you to accept and embrace
your dysfunction as an identity
that's what ashantis Jones is all about
and I gleaned all of that just by
looking at our website for a few seconds
but there is a caveat to this um
non-judgmental affirmative model because
when you dig just a little bit deeper it
doesn't take long before you discover
that the non-judgmental types are in
fact extremely judgmental they will
judge you up and down in six ways from
Sunday they will judge both your
behavior and your motivations they'll
claim the power to peer inside your very
soul and pass judgment on it
it's just that they will judge wrongly
so this is what you can know about every
single person who brags about their own
lack of judgment in every case every
time
these will be the most judgmental people
you ever come across in your life they
don't practice no judgment they practice
bad judgment everybody judges okay it's
not possible to be a sentient being in
the world without engaging in Acts of
judgment nearly every waking moment of
the day every waking moment you're
making judgment calls you're making
decisions
the anti-judgment movement is really a
movement away from good judgment and
towards bad judgment foolish judgment
destructive judgment
these are people who judge without
wisdom
which leads us to this recent Tick Tock
video from wellness coach ashantis Jones
where she uh non-judgmentally explains
that anyone who tries to lose weight is
a fat phobic bigot listen
another great question this person was
asking if there is any time in which
intentional weight loss is not fat
phobic
going to say 9.9 of the times
if you are intentionally losing weight
it is fat phobic I'm leaving that point
level zero one percent in case I am
truly truly wrong but I don't think I am
and here's the reason why I'm not saying
if you exercise
and happen to lose weight that that is
fat fat phobic
I'm not saying if you start a medication
and you happen to lose weight that is
fat phobic
I am not saying that if you're going
through any type of you know illness and
that is altering your body in some way
that that is fat phobic I'm saying when
you are intentionally exercising to lose
weight altering your diet to lose weight
doing any activity
intentionally to lose weight is fat
phobic and the reason why is because you
are intentionally attempting to make
your body smaller to fit into what
narrative The Narrative that smaller is
healthier even though we've already
discussed why that's not true
oh well thank God that's a relief don't
worry folks ashantis Jones has given you
permission to lose weight if you have an
illness
so if a terminal disease is ravaging
your body and you're withering away and
you happen to lose weight ashantis will
give you a get out of fat phobia free
card she'll even come to the hospital
and deliver last rights absolving you of
fat phobia so you can you won't be
condemned eternally in the afterlife she
is a merciful Master indeed in her
generosity she has even allowed us to
lose weight as a result of exercise so
long as losing weight wasn't the goal so
if you're going for a run around the
neighborhood because you want to work
off your beer gut you are fat phobic
scum and you should die but if you're
sprinting through an airport terminal
because you want to get to the Dairy
Queen at the food court before the
flight boards in 15 minutes that will be
acceptable in one case you're exercising
for the sake of losing weight in the
other case you're exercising with the
intent of stuffing your fat face with
ice cream these are the sorts of nuances
that we need ashantis Jones to help us
navigate this is why she's the
professional you know men hate going to
the doctor I know I do you have to make
your appointment spend half your day
sitting around in the waiting room and
often a door and uncomfortable
conversations about your body with
another man you hardly know Rex MD
understands that no one likes going to
the doctor's office that's why they've
created a safe online platform for men
to discreetly consult with licensed
Physicians and get personalized
treatment plans Rex MD makes it easy and
inexpensive to get generic and branded
Viagra and Cialis online no waiting
rooms no embarrassing trips to the
doctors no insurance no co-pays you know
Viagra can cost 90 a pill well Rex MD
has generic Viagra for just as low as a
two dollars a pill quite a savings there
just fill out their online medical
questionnaire a doctor will review your
situation and if appropriate prescribe
your medication as well your medication
will ship right to your door with free
two-day shipping it's fast simple and
cheap plus you can access your us
license Rex MD physician anytime you
need Rex MD has already helped over 300
000 guys gain confidence quickly and
conveniently their here to help you too
you can take advantage of their best
deal yet at rexmd.com Walsh and save up
to 90 off by paying only two dollars per
dosage that's rexmd.com walls for up to
90 off go to rexmd.com for more details
and safety information
if you've been thinking about uh going
back to school to finish your degree or
are you just starting your college
Journey but have little time to be in
person with classes Grant County
University's online programs are
designed to make earning your degree
easy and accessible no matter your age
or your stage in life whether you're a
busy professional looking to advance
your career or a stay-at-home parent
juggling family responsibilities their
online courses give you the flexibility
you need to learn on your own terms
Grand Canyon University specializes in
helping you fit your bachelor's Masters
or doctoral degree into your busy day
from scholarships to customized
scheduling your graduation team led by
your own GCU counselor provides you with
the personal support you need to succeed
so why wait if you're ready to take your
education to the next level you need
Grand Canyon University find your
purpose at Grand Canyon University visit
gcu.edu that's gcu.edu
now I'm not going to waste a lot of time
explaining once again why the concept of
fat phobia is nonsensical phobias are
irrational fears by definition a fear of
becoming fat is not irrational given
that fatness comes with heart disease
cancer dozens of other negative health
health outcome outcomes and yes fatness
also looks displeasing fatness is not
attractive because it is unhealthy we
are wired to be attracted to health and
vitality not disease and decay
now it's not that everyone who's even
slightly overweight is automatically
ugly but that nobody is attractive
because they are overweight this is why
a slogan like fat is beautiful is not
only morally problematic as it
encourages people to engage in
self-destructive Behavior but also
factually wrong
fatness itself is not beautiful fatness
fatness is excessive lard on the body
okay that's what fat is it's a lard
you're carrying around on your body
there's nothing inherently appealing
about that if an overweight person is
beautiful it is in spite of being fat
not because of it but aside from uh the
aesthetic concerns the main point is
that again fatness will disable you
fatness will kill you
and that provides very rational reasons
to fear it it is not fat phobia it is
fat realism
but it's not a misunderstanding about
obesity that drives the fat acceptance
movement even ashantis Jones understands
that you know objectively
by every measure it is better to be
physically fit than physically fat yet
she along with all the other fat
Advocates admonishes you for dieting and
exercise and tries to you know if you
try to improve yourself simply because
your self-improvement makes her feel
worse about herself that's what this is
okay we all need to understand that this
is so much of of what drives the wokism
on the individual level it is an
ideology of envy people who are unhappy
with their lives
dissatisfied with their own choices but
yet lack the discipline and courage to
make the necessary changes people who
have no self-control no ability to
moderate no capacity for delayed
gratification
people who are not healthy not well
adjusted therefore don't want you to be
either
and this is the case whether we're
talking about fat acceptance or gender
identity really anything else
everything you hear from that side is
motivated at least on some level
by the fact that they are unhappy
and your happiness makes them feel even
less Happy by comparison
the attack on the nuclear family is most
especially fueled by this mentality lots
of people who came from broken families
and then grew up and created more broken
families absolutely despise those of us
who have happy intact families
they're like the the five-year-old bully
at the beach who can't figure out how to
make a good sand castle so he knocks
down other kids sand castles instead
so much of the madness that groups hold
of our culture right now is driven by
motivations not any more complicated
than that
they don't want you to be happy because
they're not happy they don't want you to
be healthy because they aren't healthy
and they're not going to put the work in
and the fat except in that acceptance
Advocate who Advocates fat acceptance
purely because she's too lazy to go for
a jog is really the perfect example of
this which is why our friend shantus
Jones is today canceled that'll do it
for this portion of shows move over to
members block you can become a member
today by using Code wall should check
out for two months free on all annual
plans
um
see over there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]